so last night I saw talk to me the new
horror movie from a24 and I wanted to
share my thoughts in it there will not
be spoilers I had kind of mixed feelings
about the movie but overall I did enjoy
it and it probably does go down as one
of the better horror movies of this year
it's all about this teenagers who come
into possession of this hand and if you
hold the hand and say talk to me then it
allows you to communicate with the dad
and it does play with that Trope that
we've seen a million times now of one of
the characters trying to reach a loved
one on the other side and being drawn
too far into the world of the spirits on
the other hand pun intended it still
does feel kind of fresh and I think
that's because of the character
relationships like a lot of a24 movies
there's some intentional ambiguity but I
do overall like how it didn't spoon feed
us and gave me something to think about
after the movie had ended this movie was
directed by Michael and Danny philippu
they're better known as the YouTube
channel rockaraka but it's pretty cool
to see that this movie was successful
it's keeping up with the trend of
YouTubers making pretty decent horror
movies so if you haven't seen this movie
I definitely recommend you go check it
out go support it and let me know your
thoughts on talk to me in the comments